i think uh you know a lot of what we're
seeing with the the artificial inflation
of demand and the suppression of supply
feels like the great reset you're
familiar with the great reset and all
that
it's mass social conditioning where
if you abruptly come out like bloomberg
you know michael bloomberg in new york
said he wanted to tax
sodas or whatever and he was like we
should tax the poor because they're too
stupid
if you come out right away and prohibit
something people will revolt you've
taken something from them
but if you just it's not available and
then over a couple of weeks people break
their routines and within a month nobody
cares anymore they forget about whatever
that was
you can mass socially engineer people by
shutting down the supply for certain
things
so you get people as many people as
possible not to work
you limit the amount of stuff wait a
month then people won't be
looking for stuff they'll be completely
over it so it feels like with that and
with the housing market stuff
it's very much a you will own nothing
and you will be happy
right uh i i
we'll see when we come to a limit i mean
there
there's uh there there's a writer i like
very much
uh whose name is lee harris we share
we share a first name and the argument
that he makes is that a lot of american
freedom
what a lot of american freedom is about
is about american stubbornness
it's not necessarily people saying all
the time i have these wonderful
high ideals i have these marvelous
principles i must live by
it's more like you can't tell me to do
that i'm just not going to do it
right i think i think we saw in the past
year that more than half the country
will just do that
yeah absolutely i had last night i had
kind of a reckoning where i was i saw
some image of like if you don't have
if you're not vaccinated you're a
vaccine card you can't come in like to a
restaurant somewhere some picture on
twitter
and i just resigned myself to all the
things that i'll never be able to do
and i'm okay with it maybe i'll never go
to europe maybe i'll never travel around
asia maybe i'll never go back to new
york city
this was a european restaurant i don't
know it was just a picture it was in
english the sign was
i imagined it was new york city i don't
know for sure but you know sad
whatever i'm stubborn right they're
doing they're doing vaccine segregation
in a lot of these places
it's not outright banning well a lot of
these places i mean if you're talking
about restaurants in new york i mean
new york is not new york is not in great
shape when you think about what's going
to happen
what will the power of new york look
like will new york have the power
to set the agenda like that a lot of
commercial real estate is commercial
real estate new york i assume
is in really bad shape right now why
because people have figured out after
three decades of talking about
telecommuting
people have actually telecommuted right
they let
they defunded the police they let
rioters run wild in the streets of new
york
without the commercial real estate how
many restaurants you're going to have
so how many restaurants are going to be
able to afford say unless you have that
vaccine you can't come in here
they'll be like please come in well so
we'll sit you
we'll sit you at a nice table right here
depends on how much of a karen people of
new york are
because if you get it's really about the
demand if people in new york are just
like
you sh we're not conservatives we're not
republicans why aren't you testing for
vex right
vice.com said um you know we have
vaccine passports why aren't we using
them we should be mandated
people in new york are going to be
demanding they're going to what i'm
worried is they'll go to a cafe
and they'll open the door excuse me i
couldn't help but notice you don't have
any vax
testing or excelsior pass no we don't do
it here uh
i'm not going here that's unsafe and
then if i oh no no no we'll we'll do it
we'll do it
we'll we'll implement that i don't know
what are the chances i mean
new yorkers like to pride themselves on
being very tough and hardy
so what are the chances are people gonna
say like well we're going to open up the
we're going to open up the fireman's bar
where people come in here
you know we've got a couple of firemen
and firemen and cops who own this bar
and believe me you don't have to wear a
mask to get in here you know some people
don't even wear pants to get in here
so welcome come on in i guess it just
depends on you know you look at the
conformity
of the modern left and it's also because
um
it's also people who are more likely to
be conservative
or or or at least they were liberals who
became disaffected they left these
places
yeah they leave new york they leave la
they leave chicago and so the people who
remain
are the culti fallen line right do
whatever they're talking a lot of them
though they've moved out to places like
connecticut
or they've moved out to long island or
they're just hiding in their apartments
they're not going out at all they're
barely going out at all
the the the if you look at everything
that happened last year it's very much a
restriction on supply and forcing people
to move out of cities
it is it's amazing i mean you have this
uh this great reset from the world
economic forum where it says in 10 years
you will own nothing you'll be happy
then you get all these
you should eat the bugs articles you
don't you don't want to buy a house
don't buy a house
just be just be a renter for the rest of
your life and don't have a family don't
have kids
yeah uh the bugs articles actually
actually i kind of get a kick out of
that because it just seems so absurd and
it seems so over the top
it actually seems you know who i always
i read those bugs articles and i think
that they're actually gooning the tech
guys
because a lot of those guys in silicon
valley are so hyped up on hygiene
whenever i read those articles they
imagine they're actually talking to bill
gates
right bill gates is grossed out by beef
what is he thinking about eating cicadas
so actually i get a kick out of those
yeah but but uh you know when
when the great reset uh uh i mean it's
happening now
when they take away the beef why
shouldn't they take it away i don't
think they're gonna ban beef
i think what's gonna happen is we're
already facing beef and chicken
shortages
it's just becoming economically
difficult to to to
perform for whatever reason be it
regulatory or otherwise well i assure
you
uh like have you seen the movie v for
vendetta oh yeah sure when
when natalie portman's in v's
headquarters and she's like is this real
butter
and he's like yes he's like where did
you get it and he goes from chancellor
suttler's you know private train
carriage or whatever
yeah the the the elites right oh they're
gonna have the sweetest
juiciest grass-fed filet mignon and you
are going to be eating
cell grown fatless ground chunk
is it in uh soylent green or is it in
one of the planet of the apes movies
where tarleton heston comes upon a
beautiful strawberry
i think it's just a single strawberry
yeah right but that's that's a
plenty of episode right because heston
was in planet of the apes yeah he was
also in soil and green though
yeah that's that's right and this guy
never seen it oh yeah
that's fantastic and he's got the great
scene at the end of planet this was the
movie called sound good
uh i think yeah yeah sure what's up with
the eddie what's called edward g
robinson oh yeah it's so long ago i
haven't seen it oh yeah it's big
especially now with people talk freaking
out about beef
and yeah you know it's it's great do you
hear a fun movie here starbucks is
having shortages of like lids cups
syrups
apples for what there's just there's
mass shortages across the board
i'll tell you i saw the story today it
said starbucks facing shortages across
the nation
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
brag because if you've been watching
this show i've been warning
about the shortages that are coming so a
month ago or longer maybe even two
months ago
i was like hey something really weird's
happening there's b
there's meat shortages but it's only
being reported in local markets
like you look at omaha local news and
they're like hey we got no meat
but nationally no one's saying anything
about it
all of a sudden now the stores are
trying to pop up chicken and beef
shortages starbucks is the shortage of
plastic goods cups lids
they're saying people are coming into
starbucks they can't get their favorite
drinks there's no mocha
someone sent me a photo from a starbucks
in the dc area and it's just like
uh there's like a list on the door
saying like we're out of these things
and so it's like nothing
they have nothing they have coffee huh
yeah it's a great beginning to like a
zombie apocalypse
i can't get my mocha well here's
something i was really surprised about
today i got uh i i picked up picked up
some gum
at the at the airport coming in and
there was a sign at the cashiers and
maybe you guys have heard of this i have
not
there is now a national coin shortage
did you get that's been going on for a
year oh it is
i've heard yeah and i just heard about
it wow that's
really weird stuff happens how does that
happen what is the explanation for the
national
coin shore they probably want to make
ammo maybe they're pulling
the copper off the pennies they're
mostly yeah
for a jacket copper jacket yeah i don't
know i think what's in nickel is well i
like
zinc and nickel i think i think they
don't use copper anymore
you know because it's too valuable yeah
now they're using zinc and other
most nickels are like 95 zinc and
they're coated in nickel now they used
to be pure nickel but a shortage i mean
this is just bizarre
i i came up with people just not using
cash and i was like
people are ordering everything i've seen
that too people aren't people freak out
now
people freak out sometimes when you hand
them right dirty i'm like whether
whether it's intentional or not
it's very much a uh massive societal
transformation
you know so it could just be oh you know
jeez you know this pandemic happened
and then all of a sudden this you know
these big shifts cause massive
societal change uh it's interesting when
you read about the great reset they talk
about the conspiracy theory of it and i
can't figure out what they're accusing
of
being a conspiracy theory so if you look
up the wikipedia page for the great
reset it's like the great reset is a
proposal from the world economic forum
and international you know
interests that are advocating for a
reset of global capitalism to change the
behaviors of people and
yada yada instill a more stakeholder
focused view of the world
and you know save the plan there's a big
list of things they want and then it
says
a section says conspiracy theory yeah
but it doesn't actually say
what what's a conspiracy about it right
it's like many people on the far right
claim there's a conspiracy theory
and i'm like okay if you just told me
there's literally glo
like wealthy elite the davos group
advocating for these things that are
literally happening
i'm not sure what you're accusing of
being the conspiracy theory in this i i
don't i don't know where that says like
this is literally a thing yeah now i
guess the conspiracy theory is that they
you know faked covet or whatever which
you know i don't think that that's
ridiculous i think
we're learning now with lab league stuff
seems like a big screw-up on their part
on the part of the wuhan lab and
fouche's funding and all that stuff but
they're certainly exploiting the crisis
for some kind of great reset yes
absolutely i i i i
having some experiences being called a
conspiracy theorist having reported
on the having reported on russiagate and
having reported
what really happened that the fbi uh the
fbi spied on
you know spied on donald trump that this
is what was going on
donald trump is not a russian agent it's
not a russian spy
yeah basically whatever they're using
whenever they're
using the label conspiracy theorists
they're using it to smear someone
and not the person necessarily as much
as the argument right
so anyone who holds this opinion anyone
who makes this argument
is a lunatic it needs to be dismissed i
want to make a correction on about the
pennies and nickels pennies are made of
zinc coated with copper
nickels are made of a 75 copper 25
nickel alloy all right that's a lot of
copper yeah aren't they worth more in
copper than they are in nickels now
like as currency sounds right maybe
that's why there's a coin yeah
probably that's right they've got to
figure it out i mean that's always been
i think i think uh yeah that the medals
are worth more than the the pennies
themselves
i was reading that i don't know what's
copper
copper is currently at i don't know i
think i was reading somewhere a few
years ago it was like a nichols cop
a nickel which is the coin has a certain
amount of copper which is worth like
seven point five cents
what or like seven cents but the nickel
itself is only worth five so
i i i it's illegal to do this my
understanding like melting worth about
seven cents a nickel
that's what this says a nickel a
nickel's metal it's worth seven cents
how interesting wow is that what it says
yeah according to uh coins.fund
thefuntimesguy.com i've never heard of
it but yeah when was the last time
anyone's held a nickel to be honest
i haven't yet really yeah i haven't in a
little while
yeah it's been a few years my son just
got a piggy bank with seven pennies
those are the only seven pennies in the
house
no no it's only it's only been about
eight months i have a bag of change for
my pigment well this is a way to keep up
with inflation if we can just start
treating those coins as seven cents
worth
they don't have to be worth five seconds
why they were metals
but it just changed the value of the
coins you used to be nickels gets you 30
cents a nickel gives you
seven used to be it used to be silver
you can buy bags of old silver american
currency and it's worth way more
that's a that's a really weird thing
people i was reading stories about how
people would like
seek out specific nickels melt them down
dude it's so get the copper out
think about what that means again i'm
pretty sure it's illegal so you don't do
this
right but you could go to a bank and be
like i would like all of your nickels i
just need nickels it's an arcade machine
i got back home so here's 100 bucks
give me the nickels and then you get uh
that said two
yeah i think it is free money uh illegal
to destroy currency yeah
federal property on purpose well then i
i've got a different idea kind of a
variation on this i
i you know in washington dc they charge
you five cents at the
the cashier if you want a bag that's why
a lot of people take their own bags from
home
but i figured i would i would set up a
little stand in front of a lot of the
major supermarkets
selling plastic bags for three cents
undercut them and basically wipe out
giant
and stuff like that we like that yeah
three cents
yeah three seconds you need a bag that's
right they got this bag for three cents
you need an umbrella too there you go
this sounds similar to the book that
you're working on
a lot of the stuff you're studying about
i wonder have you studied the global
reset the
the great reset uh through different
again my my main focus the last couple
years um
has been the corruption of our elites so
yes
absolutely the way that our elites have
been
targeting have been targeting the
american public
absolutely that this is this is
definitely an important aspect of this
have you been able to track any
connections
to any of that stuff
um what i would say is again my
my my main interest right now is looking
in particular at our elites in china
right so if we're talking about
different combinations
in a sense the chinese communist party
is the platform
for the global the global realignment
if you're talking about the great reset
the chinese that's why it was very
important
to get the chinese into the into the
world trade organization
in 2001. that's why it was very
important for the clinton administration
in 1994
to de-link human rights from trade and i
want to make clear while i think that
the way the chinese government
the chinese communist party treats its
own citizens
is is something that we should be paying
attention to
our main focus as americans and our
leaders should be on american human
rights and how americans are treated
my point however is when you saw and
this was bipartisan
it wasn't just bill clinton remember
this started with henry kissinger
right started with kissinger uh reaching
out to china the opening there
so yes i think we've seen uh steady
progress starting
certainly exaggerated in 1994
i think that our elites basically
american elites specifically
gave up on american democracy and this
was the deal they made
china happen to be the the great power
with an enormous cheap labor force but
absolutely this is what's been going on
it's it's it's
it's not by accident it's purposeful
right and you go back and you look at
the different reports from the period
if you see what's still happening now
right no one is embarrassed at this
point
when they're when they talk about the
great uh the great reset as a conspiracy
theory
no one is embarrassed to say these
different things joe biden wasn't
embarrassed
on his first day in office to get rid of
the to get rid of the keystone pipeline
right none of them are embarrassed about
it how much how much this is going to
hurt the american people
they're all very upfront about it they
don't care
it's amazing i mean this this past
election was the country itself
versus subversion of the country you had
people genuinely convinced
trump was the subversion when trump was
actually the pro-america guy
joe biden is the very much i don't i
could care less about americans kamala
harris i could care less about americans
right
they don't care at all right the
language one of the most important
things i think that's happened
as part of the as part of the political
and part of the spiritual and part of
the intellectual moves against us
the way that the the language has
changed right
i know that this is something that you
guys are interested in which is
fascinating to me
the idea of left and right liberal and
conservative how these things have
flipped around
well i'm sorry how is it how is it um
how is it a liberal or a left-wing value
to start siding with what the fbi is
doing to american citizens
since when is that a left-wing value
since when is it a liberal value to
think
that um immigration mass illegal
immigration
that is designed to hurt american
working people including
latinos right that this is a liberal
thing
just let people in here and we're gonna
drive the prices down
and we're going to hurt american workers
how is that a liberal thing none of
these things are liberal it's it's one
of the greatest de-radicalizations in
the history of this country
i mean i know tons of hackers former
anonymous individuals
you know the anonymous hacking group and
antifa who are posting on facebook
celebrating the fbi and i i
you know i commented them like just i'm
glad to hear that you guys have finally
uh come to your senses and you respect
the federal government
and you're in line with law enforcement
how did this happen how did it i mean
what do they say
they just say yeah well trump's a
fascist so it's good and i was like yeah
yeah support the federal government when
they go after your political enemies
right that's right
i've been telling you this right you
support when the fbi goes after
political incidents it's fantastic
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you